me qui en ont compris les mécanismes qui
protège jusqu'au masques qu'ils doivent
désormais porter dans les salles de
classe aux plus âgés qui pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux vivent la solitude
comme un quotidien les causes en sont
multiples dans nos vies sont bouleversés
en profondeur c'est d'abord la
confrontation directe avec la mort pour
un certain nombre de familles c'est
ensuite l'angoissent pour ceux qui sont
tombés malades de faire une forme grave
et pour ceux qui ont guéri de possibles
séquelles
c'est la crainte de contaminer ses
proches et parfois la culpabilité de les
avoir contaminé c'est encore la grande
part d'inconnu de cette maladie malgré
les réels progrès en matière de
connaissance c'est le revers de la
distanciation physique qui peut
favoriser l' isolement
le repli sur soi la perte du lien avec
les autres c'est l'incertitude générée
par les conséquences économiques et
financières de la maladie tant
individuelles que collectives comme la
peur la peur de perdre son emploi
ce sont les effets du confinement avec
une promiscuité qui peut induire des
tensions conjugales des tensions
familiales voire des violences
intrafamiliales je voudrais à ce titre
parce que c'est fondamental rappelé le
dispositif 119 porté par adrien taquet
secrétaire d'état à la famille qui
permet de signaler toute situation dans
laquelle un enfant se trouverait
confronté à des violences
certaines catégories de français sont
encore plus exposés à ces troubles
psychologiques
je pense en particulier aux étudiants
être étudiant ce n'est déjà pas facile
en temps normal
l'avenir est incertain parfois on doute
le confort matériel est limité et bien
souvent il faut travailler pour financer
ses études pendant l'épidémie bien au
delà des enseignements qui ont lieu à
distance organisé par frédéric vidal à
ministre en charge de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
bien au delà de l'organisation
complètement chamboulé d'un grand nombre
de cursus
c'est toute la vie étudiante qui est mis
en suspens pendant le premier
confinement près d'un étudiant sur trois
a présenté des signes de détresse
psychologique
les étudiants étrangers est en
difficulté financière sont apparues
particulièrement fragile
je pense également à tous ceux qui
travaillent à ceux qui ont poursuivi
leur activité dans des conditions
parfois difficiles
il ya tous ceux qui doivent télétravail
est évidemment tous ceux qui
souhaiteraient travailler mais en soit
empêché notamment les restaurateurs les
acteurs du monde de la nuit les
commerçants les gérants des salles de
sport qui bien que fortement accompagné
par l'état bruno le maire en a présenté
les dispositifs la semaine dernière ne
peuvent vivre actuellement du fruit de
leur travail qui constitue d'ailleurs
bien souvent leur patrimoine
je pense évidemment aux personnes déjà
suivi pour des troubles psychologiques
ou des troubles psychiatriques
si les établissements de santé mentale
semblent avoir été relativement peu
touchée par le virus pendant la première
vague
cette crise a souligné toute
l'importance de ces structures de soins
dans nos politiques de santé et surtout
l'extraordinaire capacité des
professionnels de la santé mentale à se
réorganiser en un temps record je pense
enfin aux personnes âgées qui ont dû
renoncer à bien des plaisirs qui
jalonnent le quotidien voir des amis
accueillir enfants petits enfants
participer à des activités associatives
à des manifestations culturelles
sportives citoyenne dès le début de
cette crise sanitaire
nous avons fait le maximum pour les
protéger au mieux contre ce virus mais
aussi contre un mal qui les frappe trop
souvent et qu'il nous faut combattre à
tout prix je pense évidemment à la
solitude et à l' isolement
brigitte bourguignon il reviendra et je
tiens à saluer l'engagement de tous les
professionnels du soin et du prendre
soin à domicile comme une institution et
qui ont montré plus que jamais qu'ils
étaient indispensables pour faire
société
pour beaucoup d'entre vous pour beaucoup
d'entre nous le confinement de la
première vague a constitué un choc
ravivées par le nouveau confinement
chacun se sentira concerné si je dis
qu'il ya eu de la peur parfois de la
sidération tantôt de l'espoir tantôt du
désespoir de l'incompréhension de
l'agacement et parfois même de la colère
et parfois ses sentiments peuvent
devenir trop lourd à porter seul jusqu'à
dans les cas extrêmes finir par envahir
notre quotidien
dans ces situations il faut pouvoir
trouver de l'aide et se tourner vers les
professionnels de
santé mentale la santé mentale des
français c'est ainsi significativement
dégradée entre fin septembre et début
novembre avec une augmentation
conséquente des syndromes dépressifs
observée pour tous les profils socio
démographique elle s'avère encore plus
marquée pour les personnes déclarant une
situation financière difficile mais
aussi pour les 18 24 ans et enfin pour
les personnes qui déclarent déjà des
antécédents sur le plan psychiatrique
par ailleurs on observe depuis fin août
une augmentation continue et globalement
significative des états anxieux ainsi
qu'une diminution de la deûle
indicateurs qu'on appelle satisfaction
de vie au delà de ces statistiques il y
à l'expérience vécue et derrière le
monde des chiffres il y a le monde de la
vie et chacun d'entre nous en dur cette
épreuve avec ses difficultés ses doutes
ses craintes et ses angoisses
je voudrais vous dire qu'à aucun moment
le gouvernement n'a négligé cette
dimension de la crise sanitaire et que
nous restons particulièrement vigilant
dans la période actuelle est actif la
dimension psychologique de cette crise
est en effet tout aussi importante que
son pendant somatiques dès le 16 mars
une cellule de crise dédié qu'ovide
santé mentale s'est mise en place et
dans un souci évident de continuité des
soins
j'ai demandé qu'une attention
particulière soit apportée au maintien
de l'offre en santé mentale incluant les
patients souffrant d'addictions le ségur
de la santé n'a pas esquivé l'enjeu de
la santé mentale et se propose de
développer et d'investir massivement
dans les soins psychologiques dans
l'ensemble du pays
plus concrètement encore voici ce que
nous avons fait quarante et une cellule
d'urgence médico-psychologique ont été
dotés de moyens supplémentaires avec des
binômes psychologues infirmiers et rien
que pour la première vague ces cellules
ont assuré 8000 prise en charge de
personnes qui étaient en demande
160 psychologue supplémentaires sont
actuellement en cours de recrutement
dans les centres médico psychologiques
avec elisabeth bornes
conscient du fait que le télétravail
peut être pesant nous avons réactivé le
numéro vert le numéro que je vous
redonne qui est important le 0 800 130
000 0 800 30
000 c'est un dispositif qui a enregistré
depuis le mois d'avril
plus de deux millions d'appels et qui
actuellement enregistre plus près de
vingt mille appels par jour je remercie
les associations nationales qui
permettent de faire fonctionner ce
numéro grand public notamment la croix
rouge
sida info service sos amitié et sos
crise il existe également de nombreuses
autres plateformes d'écouté
d'intervention portés par les
collectivités ou par des associations
sur tout le territoire
mesdames messieurs si j'ai tenu à parler
de santé mentale c'est parce que les
contraintes qui vous sont imposés pour
lutter contre ce virus ne sont pas
anodines elles ne sont pas sans
conséquences nous devons rester très
attentif très vigilant et vous devez
chaque fois que cela est nécessaire
pouvoir mettre des mots sur vos maux
pouvoir parler pouvoir être écouté
chacun sera j'en suis sûr concilier
réconfort responsabilités parce que s'il
ya bien une chose qui n'est pas
obligatoire dans la période
c'est bien d'être malheureux nous
vaincrons cette vague
nous vaincrons cette pandémie nous terra
seront ensemble ce virus cela prendra du
temps encore cela mobilisera toutes nos
capacités à tenir dans la durée avec
vigilance en solidarité les uns avec les
autres et entre les générations la
recherche l'identification de traitement
et bientôt de vaccins nous aiderons dans
ce combat sans plus attendre je laisse
la parole à jérôme salomon directeur
général de la santé qui va faire un
point sur la situation épidémiologique
merci messieurs ministre bonsoir à
toutes et à tous la tension hospitalière
reste forte sur le territoire et en
particulier en auvergne rhône-alpes et
en bourgogne franche comté la france
comme de nombreux pays d'europe affronte
toujours une pression épidémique élevé
vous pouvez le voir sur cette carte
l'europe toute entière est touché par la
deuxième vague malgré des mesures de
prévention multiples mises en place
depuis des mois par la plupart des pays
nous pouvons d'ailleurs observé que de
nombreux pays qui ont traversé la
première vague sans difficulté sont
aujourd'hui très touché par cette 2
mveng en dépit de démarche différente
selon les pays
aucun n'était pas reniée par cette vague
massive
face à cette évolution au cours d'une
saison favorable de la diffusion des
virus
nous agissons avec humilité et prudence
de nombreux pays d'europe affichent des
taux d'incidence très élevé supérieur ou
similaire à celui de la france c'est le
cas de nos voisins la belgique le
luxembourg l'italie l'espagne le
royaume-uni mais aussi la suisse est un
peu plus loin la suède et l'autriche
la plupart des pays européens ont
instauré des mesures fortes de freinage
épidémique couvre-feu interdiction des
rassemblements fermeture des activités à
risque confinement en france depuis le
début de l'épidémie
2 millions 86 milles 288 personnes ont
eu un test de positif pour la co vite 19
le nombre de cas en france reste
particulièrement élevée toutefois comme
vous pouvez le constater le r effectif
est depuis quelques jours en dessous de
1 ce qui témoigne d'un ralentissement de
la circulation du virus
les trois courbes montre l'évolution de
cette cinétique de cette pente analysé
sur les tests les passages aux urgences
et les admissions hospitalières avec un
air évoluant désormais entre 0 65 et 0
89 comme vous le voyez le taux
d'incidence qui est calculée sur 7 jours
cumulés et pour 100000 habitants baisse
mais reste très au-dessus du cap fixé
par le président de la république
les deux régions les plus touchées
auvergne rhône-alpes et bourgogne
franche comté ont des taux d'incidence
très supérieur à la moyenne nationale
plusieurs départements d'auvergne rhône
alpes ont même des incidences deux fois
supérieur à la moyenne nationale le taux
d'incidence chez les personnes âgées est
au dessus de cette moyenne nationale ce
qui nous préoccupe car comme vous le
savez les personnes âgées sont
susceptibles de déborder développer des
formes plus sévères de la maladie qu
vide
enfin la pression sur nos équipes
soignantes et les établissements de
santé restent très élevés ce jour 30
2345 malades sont hospitalisés dont 6000
donc pardon 4653 en situation très
graves en réanimation au cours des sept
derniers jours ce sont 15 1807 nouveaux
malades qui ont été hospitalisés et 2483
nouvelles personnes qui ont été admise
dans un service de réanimation
enfin au cours des dernières 24 heures
se sont quand même plus de 2200 malades
ont été hospitalisés et 311 en
réanimation c'est encore beaucoup pour
préciser sur le l'auvergne rhône-alpes
il y actuellement 829 malades graves en
réanimation et 235 en bourgogne franche
comté ce qui est très important pour une
région qui est beaucoup plus petite que
l'auvergne rhône-alpes
enfin nous avons dû réaliser 150 deux
évacuations sanitaires pour soutenir en
particulier ces deux régions
bonne nouvelle depuis le 1er mars ce
sont 147 1569 personnes qui sont
retournés à domicile après un séjour
hospitalier
le nombre total de décès depuis le début
de la pandémie en france est de 47 1127
dont 30 de 1597 parmi les personnes
hospitalisées et 14 1530 parmi des
résidents en ehpad ou autres
établissements médico sociaux
nous restons donc très vigilants à
protéger au mieux les personnes les plus
fragiles et nos aînés merci beaucoup
professeur salomon pour eux pour ce
point comme vous l'avez dit professeur
les indicateurs épidémiologique
s'améliore c'est à dire que la dynamique
épidémique s'est réduite et que nous
enregistrons chaque jour - de nouveaux
diagnostics que le jour équivalent de la
semaine précédente
mais la pression sanitaire reste
extrêmement élevé dans notre pays et nos
hôpitaux sont encore en situation de
très fortes charges en terme de malades
vous avez ici
la courbe qui apparaît qui montre le
nombre de patients hospitalisés au cours
de la première vague mais également au
cours de la vague actuelle de la
deuxième vague vous ai constaté qu il y
a d'ores et déjà plus de patients
hospitalisés
et en france au cours de la deuxième
vague concours de la première est que
nous sommes à l'heure actuelle encore à
un niveau plus important que le pic
sanitaire enregistrés à l'hôpital
au printemps dernier ce qui atteste du
fait qu'il ne faut certainement pas
relâcher nos efforts maintenant
s'agissant des réanimations maintenant
le nombre de patients admis en
réanimation reste important au quotidien
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée au
cours des 24 derniers dernière heure
c'est comme si un patient avait été
avait été admis dans sa soeur dans un
service de réanimation toutes les 4
minutes et vous voyez sur cette courbe à
nouveau la première vague et qui
figurait et ensuite la deuxième vague de
patients admis en réanimation il y
actuellement 4700 patients environ en
réa dans nos hôpitaux c'est beaucoup il
faut ajouter à ces quatre mille 700
patients plus de 3000 à 3500 malades qui
sont également en réanimation mais pour
d'autres motifs que le coc vide un
accident de la route grave
une opération chirurgicale un accident
vasculaire cérébral ou un infarctus du
myocarde
ce qui veut dire que on est encore à
l'heure à laquelle je vous parle au
dessus de 8000 malades qui sont pris au
total qui sont pris en charge dans les
service de réa et de soins intensifs
transformer en réanimation dans nos
hôpitaux c'est vous dire que la charge
sanitaire est élevée elle va se réduire
jour après jour progressivement mais
elle est encore très élevé et nous
pensons à nos soignants et aux malades
ce soir et je renouvelle mon message il
ne faut certainement pas relâcher notre
vigilance et nos efforts dans la
situation actuelle
un petit focus sur la région auvergne
rhône-alpes le professeur sall au mans
vous a dit que le diffusion du virus il
était encore plus élevé que dans le
reste du territoire
et voyez que la charge hospitalière et
la charge en réanimation est très
importante encore dans cette région
justifiant d'ailleurs des évacuations
sanitaires qui sont opérés vers d'autres
régions du territoire national plus
d'une centaine déjà ont été faites
de la même manière pour la région
bourgogne franche comté
vous pouvez constater que la charge
hospitalière est également extrêmement
élevées tout ça pour vous dire que si je
devais résumer le virus circule moins
vite qu'avant la mise en place du
confinement et qu'avant la mise en place
du couvre-feu et c'est une bonne
nouvelle c'est elle et ses attendus
mais aujourd'hui la charge samedi
reste élevé dans nos hôpitaux elle va
commencer à se réduire progressivement
elle a commencé à se réduire
progressivement mais ça va prendre du
temps et donc nous devons être
extrêmement vigilants et attentifs les
uns vis-à-vis des autres
je vais passer la parole à madame
brigitte bourguignon ministre délégué en
charge de l'autonomie qui va faire donc
un focus sur la situation des personnes
âgées vulnérables
merci monsieur le ministre je voudrais
vous faire le point sur la situation
dans les ehpad
je sais que vous êtes nombreux à vous en
inquiéter que vous soyez vous mêmes
résidents des ehpad que vous ayez un
membre de votre famille hébergée dans un
établissement ou que vous y travaillez
ce que nous voulons éviter
impérativement c'est de retrouver les
chiffres de la première vague un ehpad
sur deux avait alors été touché au
niveau national et la quasi totalité des
établissements franciliens
la situation est la suivante à l'heure
où nous parlons il y a près de 1600
ehpad touché par plusieurs cas de co
vide plus d'un ehpad sur cinq donc les
régions les plus concernées sont la
nouvelle aquitaine la provence alpes
côte d'azur
l'occitanie et les hauts de france même
si tout le territoire national est
impacté le nombre de décès augmente
depuis mi-octobre pour la semaine
écoulée le nombre de décès moyen par
jour en établissement s'est établi à 163
la situation reste donc préoccupante
toutefois nous ne sommes pas dans la
même situation que lors de la première
vague
d'abord tous les représentants de la
famille du grand âge me le disent les
professionnels sont mieux armés nous
connaissons mieux le virus et son mode
de propagation
cela signifie que les équipes sont ont
acquis les bons réflexes en matière
d'hygiène de dépistage rapide
d'organisation interne pour facile pour
limiter les contaminations
ensuite et je m'adresse directement aux
résidents nous savons qu'avec le risque
sanitaire
l'isolément est un deuxième risque
majeur et c'est celui qui d'elle que
d'ailleurs vous redoutez parfois le plus
que vous viviez en établissement ou à
domicile
le président a dit qu'il était dur
d'avoir 20 ans en 2020 je me permets
d'ajouter
et qu'il est également dur d'avoir
quatre fois 20 ans en 2020 pour protéger
sans isolés selon les mots du président
de la république nous avons tout de
suite fait le choix de ne pas suspendre
les visites de ses proches et les
interventions de professionnels
nécessaires à l'entretien de l'autonomie
c'est un choix que nous tiendrons même
si nous mesurons à quel point
l'équilibré entre protection et lien
social et délicat assuré au quotidien
sur le terrain
enfin nous avons fait monter en
puissance des dispositifs de soutien qui
avait été activé dès la première vague
je citerai quelques exemples je pense au
soutien sanitaire avec la mise en place
d'astreintes téléphonique de médecins
spécialisés pour que les équipes d pad
ne soit pas laissée seule à
l'intervention faciliter les
professionnels libéraux également de
l'hospitalisation à domicile ou encore
des équipes mobiles d'hygiène et de
gériatrie
je pense aussi au soutien en matière de
ressources humaines qui est le sujet de
préoccupation majeure des établissements
car les équipes sont fatiguées
bien souvent il n'ya pas de solution
magique mais nous activons tous les
leviers pour répondre aux besoins
notamment la mobilisation des étudiants
en santé volontaires celle de pôle
emploi qui a lancé à notre demande une
grande campagne de recrutement pour les
ehpad qui en ont besoin partout en
france celle des professionnels
volontaires qui se sont inscrits sur la
plateforme créée par le ministère des
solidarités et de la santé le nombre de
volontaires a triplé en quelques
semaines je vous adresse à remerciements
d'ailleurs chaleureux pour cet
engagement je ne peux qu'inciter tous
les professionnels à amplifier ce
mouvement afin de multiplier les chances
de répondre aux besoins cruciaux partout
sur le territoire
nous poursuivons ce travail pour
mobiliser d'autres volontés d'autres
énergies avec brigitte klinkert nous
travaillons sur la mobilisation des
associations intermédiaires du domaine
de l'insertion par l'activité économique
avec sarah et l'arrêt nous voulons
engager les
jeunes à s'engager au service civique
aux côtés des ehpad de leurs résidents
je voudrais conclure en signalant à quel
point les semaines qui suivent seront
cruciales je le répète tout se joue
maintenant pour que la deuxième vague
dans les ehpad ne ressemble pas à la
première
il faut mettre toutes les chances de
notre côté respecter notre engagement de
protéger sans isoler les résidents d pad
cela signifie que chacune et chacun doit
respecter de façon extrêmement
scrupuleuse les gestes barrières lavage
des mains port du masque en toutes
circonstances la distanciation physique
doivent être respectés très
scrupuleusement
même si je mesure à quel point ne pas
prendre ses proches dans ses bras est un
crève coeur
cela signifie aussi que nous devons
tirer parti du déploiement des ti des
tests antigénique pour éviter à tout
prix que le virus ne franchisse le seuil
de l'établissement avec olivier ferrand
nous allons transmettre ce soir une
nouvelle recommandation qui sera
applicable pour les semaines à venir
jusqu'à ce que la situation s'améliore
s'agissant des professionnels nous
recommandons désormais d'organiser des
dépistages des personnels des ehpad de
façon hebdomadaire à partir de la
semaine prochaine pour amorcer cette
dynamique l'état livres 1,6 million de
tests antigénique aux ehpad qui
s'approvisionneront ensuite eux mêmes
ces dépistages sont essentiels pour
réagir le plus vite possible afin de
repérer un éventuel cluster s'agissant
des visiteurs un auto-questionnaire
strictement personnelles et
confidentielles devra être rempli par
les proches avant leur entrée dans
l'établissement afin de le perdre de
leur permettre d'évaluer eux mêmes leur
risque de faire rentrer le virus sans
que cela ne soit une obligation
nous recommandons visiteurs d'effectuer
un test
rt pcr 72 heures avant leur entrée dans
l'établissement ou s'ils n'ont pas pu le
faire un test antigénique dans la
journée en pharmacie les proches
rendront visite très souvent résidents
pourront participer aux campagnes de
dépistage hebdomadaire des
professionnels je rappelle que même avec
un résultat négatif
il est indispensable de rester très
vigilant dans l'application des gestes
barrières
j'ai confiance de l'effort qui est
demandé à chacune et chacun en
particulier aux professionnels
ces recommandations seront aménagés dès
que possible en fonction de la situation
sanitaire
pour conclure nous souhaitons olivier
ferrand et moi même vous adresser à
toutes et tous
famille et dans soignants personnel et
directeur un salut admiratif pour la
rigueur l'engagement et l'inventivité
dont vous faites preuve au quotidien et
avoue personnes âgées
quel que soit votre lieu de vie nous
voulons dire que nous mesurons la
difficulté du moment
l'inquiétude la tristesse qui peuvent
s'installer mais aussi les efforts et la
prudence dont vous faites preuve vous
n'êtes pas seuls nous sommes et nous
serons à vos côtés tout au long de cette
crise
merci beaucoup
chez brigitte bourguignon ce point
nécessaire je le crois bien je crois
qu'il y a peut être des questions
d'abord des questions des questions
d'internautes donc une question de
charlotte les tests antigénique sont-ils
comptabilisée dans les données
nationales alors les tests antigénique
sont bien comptabilisée dans les données
nationales hier en comptait un peu plus
de 2800 diagnostic positif fait dans
l'ensemble du pays
artest antigénique qui s'ajoutait à 25
mille cinq cents cas diagnostiqués par
test pcr
nous avons intégré depuis le début de la
semaine la comptabilisation de ces tests
anti lennik dans l'application cidep qui
permet de faire remonter ces données en
toute transparence et qui sont
accessibles nous prendront bientôt nous
tiendrons bientôt compte de ces tests et
antigénique dans le calcul de tous les
indicateurs plus fins telles que le test
de positivité où le taux de dépistage
par exemple une question de sarah il n'y
a pas que dans les personnes âgées en
ehpad dont on doit s'occuper que
faites-vous pour celles qui sont seuls
et angoissé chez
elle justement sa rage j'ai parlé de ce
sujet là de l'angoissé de la solitude
aujourd'hui hier nous étions avec adrien
taquet d'ailleurs en déplacement pour
aller voir une association des coûts du
ce qui lui permet de répondre aux jeunes
cette fois ci qui se posent des
questions qui peuvent être en situation
difficile parfois d'ailleurs lié au
confinement parfois de façon
indépendante du confinement ce fil santé
jeunes qui fonctionne très bien il ya
beaucoup d'associations qui sont
mobilisés enfin tout ce dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure le réseau de soutien
psychologique qui s'est mis en place sur
l'ensemble du territoire national est
évidemment accessible à tout un chacun
quel que soit son âge ses conditions
sociales où ces questions on passe aux
questions des journalistes
bonjour le yves besson ans pour bfm tv
première question le gouvernement
envisage-t-il de rendre obligatoire
l'isolément des malades du cobp id notre
question 1 français sur 4 selon un
sondage est là pour bfm tv
je ne compte pas aller se faire vacciner
comment comptez vous convaincre ces
récalcitrants et est ce que ça pourrait
être la tâche d'un monsieur vaccin est
ce qu'il y aura une nomination de ce
genre et puis enfin jean profil vous
parler de la santé mentale tout aussi
importante pour vous reprendre vos mots
que son pendant sanitaires si les
chiffres vont dans le bon sens pourquoi
ne pas décider de rouvrir les petits
commerces pour le 27 novembre
merci bien on m'avait posé plusieurs
questions en une tête de veau répond
d'abord je voudrais saluer pardon parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le duo des est un
jour très particulier dans l'année où
nous avons le plaisir et l'honneur
d'accueillir au ministère des
solidarités de la santé trois jeunes qui
vivent avec un handicap
je pense à alexandra à manon et à
thibault qui sont présents dans la salle
et que je salue chaleureusement vous
répondre d'abord sur la côte et sur la
question qui portait sur les vaccins on
m'avait posé sur la confiance des
français
écoutez je crois que le chemin de la
confiance il se trouve avec la
transparence le partage des informations
à mesure dont nous aurons disposons
l'explication le travail de conviction
qui doit être fait et puis cette phrase
que j'ai déjà dit et que je répète
aujourd'hui le jour où nous proposerons
un vaccin aux français c'est que ce
vaccin sera à la fois sûr et efficace
sur la question des de la réduction de
l'incidence épidémique et pourquoi
est-ce-que n'ouvrons pas danser déjà un
certain nombre d'activités dans notre
pays ce n'est pas parce que le niveau de
la marée est en train de baisser
qu'on peut déjà sortir en toute quiétude
dans la réussite de faire une métaphore
c'est à dire que nous sommes encore avec
une pression épidémie qui est importante
imaginer qu'avec aujourd'hui quelque
22000 je crois véritablement 22000 23
mille cas diagnostiqués aujourd'hui nous
sommes finalement au moment de pression
épidémique qui quand on regarde avant le
confinement correspondait déjà la mise
en place du couvre feu dans un certain
nombre de métropoles est précédé de
quelques jours l'annoncé par le
président de la république du
confinement
donc c'est pas parce que ça baisse que
sebbah d'accord donc
baisse c'est parce que saab est ce que
ça fonctionne et qu'il faut continuer et
plus on applique le confinement et plus
on est solidaires et courageux dans la
période moins longtemps ça durera est
plutôt pourra reprendre une vie la plus
normale possible je crois qu'il y avait
une troisième question vous m'avez posé
qui était en fait la première sur le
fond ni les allemands obligatoire ça
fait l'objet de discussions d'un débat
dont je crois profondément qu'il doit
être un débat démocratique j'ai vu des
groupes parlementaires s'étaient emparés
de ce sujet je n'ai pas de réponse
binaire à vous faire si ce n'est que je
constate que certains pays qui ont mis
en place les allemands obligatoire font
face à une deuxième vague épidémique de
la même manière que d'autres pays qui
n'ont pas mis en place les allemands
obligatoire pour autant est-ce que ça
peut être un outil dans la mesure où
nous voulons encore développer le
triptyque tracé alerté protéger ça fait
parti d'un enjeu démocratique et je
pense que les initiatives parlementaires
sont à suivre avec intérêt
bonjour et l'abonné pour tf1 lci
je vais rebondir sur cette question de
l' isolement est ce que vous les
français vous pouvez imaginer un
scénario à la chinoise ce que vous
voulez pas aller jusque là pour les
inciter à respecter ce principe de l'
isolement et puis mon autre question
porte sur la saisonnalité du virus dans
le scénario progressive de déconfinement
que sur lequel vous travaillez ce que
vous prenez en compte ce paramètre est
ce que ça vous inquiète
est ce que ça pourrait redémarrer le
virus en quelque sorte sur les sommes en
jeu j'ai un peu répandue encore une fois
il des pays qui ont des façons très
différentes de gérer une épidémie
maintenant jérôme salomon a dit quelque
chose de très important tout à l'heure
s'agissant de la situation
internationale
c'est quand on regarde est ce qu'il ya
un pays qui arrivent à faire face à
l'épidémie de covin s'en prend ce qu'on
appelle des mesures de gestion c'est à
dire des restrictions aux libertés
individuelles ou collectives vous donner
un exemple la corée du sud
on cite souvent en exemple la corée du
sud a enregistré quelques centaines de
cas au quotidien les derniers jours et a
donc décidé de réduire les jauges des
événements de fermer un certain nombre
d'établissements qui reçoivent du public
donc en réalité tous les pays qui font
face à des résurgences épidémiques sont
obligés de prendre des mesures de
gestion quelle que soit d'ailleurs le
système d'isolement de tracking de test
qui a été mis en place à ne pas dire
qu'on peut pas faire mieux
ça veut pas dire qu'on va pas faire
mieux
on développe des tests de façon massive
on était à 2 millions de tests pcr avec
les tests antigénique on va augmenter
encore nos capacités et répondre à la
demande de tous les français et on va le
développer avec les collectivités qui
veulent travailler avec nous avec les
entreprises qui souhaitent monter des
choses dans le cadre d'un protocole
sanitaire qui fasse sens il s'agit pas
de tester pour tester mais de tester
pour pouvoir protéger justement et puis
faire du contact racing pour casser les
chaînes de contamination dans d'autres
exemples internationaux d'ailleurs
d'autres pays
je prends la nouvelle-zélande à auckland
vient de confiner le centre ville
d'auckland alors qu'on disait que la
nouvelle-zélande était à l'abri le liban
vient de prononcer un confinement
généralisée de nombreux états américains
ont mis en place un confinement
généraliser le canada également donc
tout cela nous invite à la fois la
modestie est à la fois invite à faire un
travail coopératif pour voir ce qui
fonctionne et ce qui ne fonctionne pas
peut-être qu améliorer les dispositifs
d'isolement de mise à l'abri
peut-être que développer encore plus de
moyens pour accompagner les gens quand
ils sont mis à l'abri et une façons
procédé peut-être qu'il faut une
certaine forme de contrainte
en tous les cas nous avons fait
confiance aux français depuis le début
de cette pandémie
nous voyons que la confiance paye
puisque avec le confinement qui a été
mis en place
l'incidence épidémique est en train de
se réduire de façon conséquente
quant à la saisonnalité du virus est une
très bonne question
j'espère avoir une bonne réponse
optimiste à vous à vous de donner le
virus affectée si je puis dire ainsi
lycéens en tout cas les un an de sa
découverte c'est vous dire que nous
n'avons pas véritablement de recul sur
ce qui se passe lorsque les températures
refroidissent ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que nous avons enregistrées dans
plusieurs pays européens au mois
d'octobre une accentuation épidémique
c'est le moment où lille l'italie a
commencé à redémarrer ou la suisse a
commencé à démarrer la belgique la 9 e
les pays bas puis la france qui était en
cours de maîtrise de la vague a vu à
nouveau une ascension épidémique quand
il a commencé à faire froid
et puis quand il a commencé à pleuvoir
et que l'air était plus lourd
donc évidemment nous sommes vigilants
mais je vais vous dire une chose qu'il
fasse beau ou qu'il ne fasse pas beau le
confinement à cela d'efficace qui nous
engage tous aux mêmes efforts au
quotidien pendant toute la durée de son
application
bonsoir monsieur le ministre florian
tardive pour ces newscan al plus une
question qui revient au sein de la
population quels sont les lieux où
se contaminent le plus l'institut
pasteur élabore actuellement une étude
est ce que vous avez des résultats
préliminaires est ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus et je me permet de
rebondir sur la question de mon confrère
de bfm tv
une personne sera t-elle en charge dans
notre pays est bien de piloter la
vaccination lorsque en france nous
allons avoir un vaccin efficace sûr et
homologué sur la question des lieux de
contamination il ya beaucoup d'études
qui sortent en france d'ailleurs ou à
l'étranger vous avez sans doute vu cette
étude américaine qui pointait parmi les
lieux de fréquentation extérieur hélas
le fait que les restaurants les bars
mais aussi les salles de sport il avait
été beaucoup question des salles de
sport lorsque nous avions pris la
décision à la rentrée de fermer un
certain nombre de salles de sport une
âme et salles de sport apparaissent
comme un des endroits où on se
contaminent mais aussi les offices
religieux c'est à dire finalement les
endroits où on en jour bois on transpire
et où on chante donc ça s'éteint c'est
un aspect qui est intéressant dans les
études qui sont conduites notamment par
le professeur arnaud fontanet qui a déjà
participé à des conférences de presse il
s'attache à déterminer si quelqu'un qui
a attrapé le virus
c'est nous dire comment et dans quelles
circonstances et auprès de qui est-ce
qu'il d'attraper et est ce qu'il est
capable de remonter les chaînes de
contamination pour faire ce qu'on
appelle le racing à la japonaise
les résultats sont très intermédiaires
je lui laisserai la primeur de ces
annonces lorsqu'il des publiera et vous
verrez que tout cela va dans le sens des
mesures que nous avons adoptées
quant à la stratégie vaccinale en
général d'abord vous dire que ont été
saisi la haute autorité de santé qui est
en charge de publier des recommandations
d'usagé du vaccin ou des vaccins a été
saisi le conseil consultatif national
d'éthique temps la question d'un vaccin
dans une pandémie comme celle ci peut
soulever de questionnement éthique et
l'ensemble des autorités sanitaires
évidemment l' agence du médicament est
sur le pont si je puis dire avec la
publication de données intermédiaires
par les laboratoires je comprends
parfaitement les questions qui se posent
vous apporterons toutes les réponses en
temps voulu on ne peut pas vous donner
de réponse qui soit se diraient juste et
efficace tant que nous n'avons pas accès
c'est à dire au minimum c'est-à-dire aux
données scientifiques et médicales sur
l'efficacité et l'assurance de
ces vaccins pour les populations mais
vous aurez toutes les réponses ce qui ne
nous empêche pas évidemment de
travailler avec une task force sous
l'autorité du premier ministre jean
castex qui déploie déjà énormément de
choses en matière logistique
nous prenons la dernière question
bonsoir frédérique prabonnaud france
télévisions on voit les courbes de
d'incidence dans certaines métropoles
qui ont l'air de dont la baisse a l'air
de faiblir
est ce que c'est un phénomène qui vous
inquiète t est ce qu'on aurait peut-être
sous-estimé l'effet vacances scolaires
qui pourrait avoir son effet aujourd'hui
et puis j'ai une précision pour vous
madame bourguignon à propos de
du dépistage dans les ehpad des
personnels le dépistage hebdomadaire s
qui sera obligatoire j'ai pas bien
compris ça pour l'instant les dépistages
qui avait lieu et ait été volontaire
c'est sa réponse alors sur la question
de l'évolution de l'incidence dans
certaines métropoles
est-ce qu'on a sous-estimé mais je sais
pas si je vais m'assurer film est de
toute façon c'est un constat il ya eu
des vacances scolaires et une rentrée
universitaire et éducative vous dire que
évidemment on tient compte de tous les
paramètres dans l'est dans les calculs
qui sont faits je retiens quand même que
la baisse d'une décontamination a été
dans l'ensemble sous contrôle du
directeur général de la santé plus
rapide en tout cas elle est actuellement
à un rythme plus soutenu que ce que nous
pouvions imaginer
initialement lorsque nous avions mis en
place qui ne veut pas dire que la baisse
de la pression sanitaire haye de la même
manière donc encore une fois il faut
poursuivre comme nous le faisons
aujourd'hui qui est en effet un essai
vacances ou qui est pas un effet
vacances ça ne change rien à la donne
c'est à dire la poursuite des mesures du
continent pendant toute la durée
nécessaire pour casser définitivement
cette épidémie par contre c'est une
donnée intéressante nous tiendrons
compte dans les analyses mais c'est
forcément rétrospectif voyez-vous sur le
caractère obligatoire
on va pas le formuler de cette manière
mais il va y avoir l'organisation
hebdomadaire d'une séance de dépistage
pour tout le personnel qui s'y prêtent
très volontiers parce que eux-mêmes sont
très responsables et voilà pour ce qui
concerne les visiteurs vous l'avez vous
l'avez entendu là ça repose quand même
sur une responsabilité individuelle
on est toujours sur ce concept de
liberté évidemment de chaque personne
mais aussi de responsabilité
je crois que chacun aujourd'hui
notamment lorsqu'il est angoissé par
rapport à son proche qui est dans un
établissement ne s'y prêtent très
volontiers est pour l'instant en tout
cas nous n'avons pas de remontées de
difficultés à ce niveau donc les tests
nous améliore les choses parce qu'on
peut avoir des réponses plus rapides en
cas de doute et on peut isoler plus
facilement voilà merci beaucoup
vous aurez retenu le message principal
le confinement n'est pas terminée et ce
n'est pas d'actualité
2d confiner le pays nous devons
poursuivre nos efforts pendant toute la
durée nécessaire pour casser l'épidémie
vaincre le virus nous l'avions fait au
printemps dernier nous y arriverons et
nous retrouverons une vie beaucoup plus
normal ensuite on vous remercie beaucoup